Je suis de Detroit,
(Applaudissements)
une ville qui, dans les années 50,
était le géant mondial de l'industrie,
qui comptait 1,8 million d'habitants
et 360 km² de terres et d'infrastructures
utilisées pour supporter ce centre urbain du Midwest en plein boom.
Aujourd'hui,
à peine un demi-siècle plus tard,
Detroit est le modèle du déclin urbain.
Actuellement, on y compte moins de 700 000 habitants,
dont 84% d'Afro-Américains,
et à cause de décennies de désinvestissement
et de fuite des capitaux
de la ville vers la banlieue,
il y a une pénurie à Detroit.
Il y a une pénurie dans la vente,
plus précisément, dans la vente de nourriture fraîche,
ce qui fait que 70% des habitants
sont obèses et en surpoids
et ils ont du mal.
Ils ont du mal à accéder à une nourriture nutritive indispensable,
indispensable pour rester en bonne santé,
pour éviter des maladies prématurées et liées à l'alimentation.
Beaucoup trop de personnes vivent plus près d'un fast food
d'une supérette ou d'une station-service
où ils doivent faire leurs courses
que d'un hypermarché.
Ce ne sont pas de bonnes nouvelles sur Detroit,
mais ce sont les nouvelles
et l'histoire
que les habitants ont l'intention de changer.
Non, je reprends.
C'est l'histoire que les habitants sont en train de changer
grâce à l'agriculture urbaine et l'entrepreneuriat alimentaire.
Le fait est que,
à cause de son histoire récente,
Detroit dispose maintenant
de quelques atouts uniques,
notamment des terrains non aménagés.
Les experts disent que Boston, San Francisco
et le quartier de Manhattan
ont la même superficie que cet espace vacant.
Ils continuent en affirmant
que 100 km² de la ville sont inoccupés.
Cela représente entre un quart et un tiers de la ville,
et avec un tel taux d'espaces vides,
cela crée un paysage incomparable aux autres grandes villes.
Detroit a donc ça : des terrains vacants, de la terre fertile,
de l'eau à proximité,
une main d'œuvre motivée
et un besoin urgent de nourriture fraîche et saine.
Tout ceci a engendré un mouvement citoyen
des habitants de Detroit
qui transforment cette ville
de ce qui était la capitale de l'industrie américaine
en un paradis agraire.
(Applaudissements)
Vous savez, je pense, de toutes les villes du monde,
Detroit est la mieux placée pour servir de modèle urbain mondial
en termes de sécurité alimentaire et de développement durable.
À Detroit, nous avons aujourd'hui plus de 1 500
jardins et fermes répartis partout dans la ville.
Ce ne sont pas des terrains
où poussent seulement des tomates et des carottes.
Vous voyez, l'agriculture urbaine à Detroit est une question de communauté,
parce que nous cultivons ensemble.
Ces espaces sont donc des espaces de convivialité.
Ces espaces sont des endroits où l'on construit une cohésion sociale
tout en fournissant une nourriture saine et fraîche
à nos amis, nos familles et nos voisins.
Venez marcher avec moi.
Je veux vous emmener dans quelques quartiers de Detroit
et je veux que vous voyiez ce que ça donne de valoriser le leadership local,
de soutenir les mouvements citoyens
de personnes qui redonnent de la valeur aux communautés à bas revenus
et aux personnes de couleur.
Notre premier arrêt : Oakland Avenue Farms.
Oakland Avenue Farms est situé dans le quartier le plus au Nord.
Il consistera en un espace de deux hectares
associant l'art, l'architecture, les énergies durables
et des nouvelles pratiques de vente.
Au sens le plus propre du mot,
c'est ce à quoi ressemble l'agriculture dans la ville de Detroit.
J'ai eu l'occasion de travailler avec Oakland Avenue Farms
en organisant des repas de produits directement issus des cultures locales.
Pour ces repas, on emmène les gens dans le potager,
on leur laisse le temps et l'occasion
de rencontrer, saluer et parler au producteur,
puis ils font un tour de l'exploitation.
Enfin, ils profitent d'un repas de produits « de la ferme à la table »
préparé par un chef
qui met en valeur tous les produits pile au sommet de leur fraîcheur.
On fait ça.
On emmène des personnes au potager,
on assoit des gens autour d'une table,
parce qu'on veut changer la relation des gens à la nourriture.
On veut qu'ils sachent exactement d'où leur nourriture provient,
elle est cultivée dans ce potager et est dans leur assiette.
Mon deuxième arrêt.
Je vais vous emmener dans l'ouest de Detroit,
au quartier de Brightmoor.
Aujourd'hui, Brightmoor est une communauté à faibles revenus.
Il y a environ 13 000 habitants.
Ils ont décidé de mettre en place
une stratégie pâté de maison par pâté de maison.
Dans le quartier de Brightmoor,
vous trouverez un micro quartier de 21 pâtés de maison
appelé Brightmoor Farmway.
Désormais, la célèbre communauté dangereuse et mal desservie d'antan
s'est transformée en un bel endroit accueillant et sécurisé,
regorgeant de parcs, de jardins, de fermes et de serres.
Les membres de cette communauté unie se sont aussi associés
pour acheter un bâtiment abandonné,
qui était délabré et allait être saisi.
Avec l'aide d'amis, de familles et de bénévoles,
ils ont pu retirer la vitre pare-balles,
ils ont pu nettoyer le sol
et ils ont transformé ce bâtiment en une cuisine communautaire,
en un café, en une vitrine.
Désormais, agriculteurs et artisans alimentaires vivant à Brightmoor
ont un endroit pour fabriquer et vendre leurs produits.
Et les membres de la communauté
ont un endroit où ils peuvent acheter de la nourriture fraîche et saine.
L'agriculture urbaine, et c'est mon troisième exemple,
peut être un moyen d'élever le modèle d'entreprise coopérative.
Les 1 500 fermes et jardins dont je vous parlais plus tôt ?
Keep Growing Detroit est une organisation
à qui on doit beaucoup pour ces fermes.
L'année dernière, ils ont distribué 70 000 paquets de graines
et un quart de million de semis.
Grâce à cela,
250 000 kg d'aliments
ont été cultivés dans la ville de Detroit.
(Applaudissements)
Mais à côté de tout cela,
ils gèrent et opèrent aussi une coopérative.
Celle-ci s'appelle Grown in Detroit.
Elle se compose d'environ 70 agriculteurs,
des petits agriculteurs.
Ils cultivent tous et vendent ensemble.
Ils cultivent des fruits,
des légumes,
ils cultivent des fleurs,
des herbes en sol sain,
sans produits chimiques, pesticides, engrais
ou produits génétiquement modifiés.
De la nourriture saine.
Et quand leur produit est vendu
partout dans la ville de Detroit, dans les marchés locaux,
ils reçoivent 100% des bénéfices de la vente.
Dans une ville comme Detroit,
où beaucoup trop d'Afro-Américains meurent
des suites de maladies liées à l'alimentation,
les restaurants ont un énorme rôle à jouer
pour améliorer l'accès à une nourriture saine dans la ville de Detroit,
des restaurants culturellement appropriés.
Allez à Detroit Vegan Soul.
Oui, nous avons un restaurant de soul food végétalien à Detroit.
(Applaudissements)
Oui, oui.
Detroit Vegan Soul offre aux citoyens la possibilité
de manger plus de plats à base de plantes
et ils ont reçu une réponse enthousiaste de leur part.
Ils sont avides de nourriture culturellement appropriée,
fraîche et savoureuse.
Nous avons donc créé FoodLab Detroit, une association à but non lucratif
pour aider les petits entrepreneurs s'implantant dans le quartier
à lancer et développer des entreprises d'alimentation saine.
FoodLab fournit à ces entrepreneurs une incubation de projet,
une formation pratique, des ateliers,
une assistance technique, un contact avec des experts de l'industrie
pour qu'ils puissent grandir et se développer.
Ce sont de très petites entreprises,
mais l'année dernière, elles ont eu un revenu total
de plus de 7,5 millions de dollars,
et elles ont créé 252 emplois.
Écoutez.
(Applaudissements)
Ce ne sont que quelques exemples
sur la manière de développer les opportunités
pour que tout le monde puisse participer
et prospérer,
particulièrement ceux provenant des quartiers
qui ont été historiquement exclus de ce type d'opportunités.
Je sais, je sais.
Ma ville a encore du chemin à faire.
On a encore des difficultés
et je ne vais pas me tenir ici sur cette scène et vous dire
que tous les problèmes de Detroit et tous ses défis
vont être résolus grâce à l'agriculture urbaine.
Je ne vais pas faire ça,
mais je vais vous dire ceci :
l'agriculture urbaine a permis aux citoyens d'envisager Détroit
d'une façon différente,
une ville qui peut être à la fois urbaine et rurale.
Et oui, je sais, ces exemples sont à petite échelle
et ne concernent que des quartiers
mais ils sont puissants,
parce que je vous montre comment nous bâtissons une nouvelle société
qui remplace l'ancienne à l'endroit même où elle a été détruite.
Ce sont des exemples puissants parce qu'ils parlent d'amour,
l'amour que les citoyens ont l'un pour l'autre,
l'amour que nous avons pour notre communauté, pour Mère Nature,
mais surtout, ces exemples illustrent
comment la désolation, le désespoir, le déclin
n'auront jamais le dernier mot sur la ville de Detroit.
Quand des dizaines de milliers de personnes ont quitté Detroit,
nous laissant pour morts, ceux qui sont restés avaient de l'espoir.
Ils ont gardé espoir.
Ils n'ont jamais abandonné.
Ils ont continué à se battre.
Et, je sais,
transformer une grande ville comme Detroit en une ville prospère,
fonctionnelle, saine,
ouverte, qui offre des opportunités à tous,
je sais que c'est dur,
je sais que c'est éprouvant et difficile.
Mais je crois simplement
que si nous commençons à renforcer le tissu social de nos communautés,
et si nous soutenons les projets dans nos quartiers les plus vulnérables,
tout commence par une nourriture saine, accessible,
savoureuse et culturellement appropriée.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)
Merci.